there's a lot of hype around probiotics
Oh yogurts capsules all sorts of
products that composedly contain
beneficial bacteria they've been linked
to all kinds of health claims from
nebulus ones like promote gut health and
boost immunity to specific ones like
helping to treat all kinds of disorders
that have been linked to the microbiome
from inflammatory bowel disease to
irritable bowel syndrome and more the
problem is that some of these strains
have been grown in industrialized
cultures for a very long time
they don't consist of the a-listers of
God they are strains that have been
chosen because they were historically
easier to package and grow and
manufacture and they are found in very
low concentrations so when you swallow
these products the microbes within them
don't colonize you they don't establish
themselves they disappear or they pass
through you which might explain why
these products have so few convincing
benefits there is a promise here of
course the idea of taking beneficial
microbes is a very sound one but I think
we need to get much savvy and smarter
about picking microbes that are going to
do well inside us we're not quite there
yet but it's something that scientists
are very actively looking at